okay so let's continue with our tour of
yesterday's white house coronavirus
press briefing i already went over parts
uh i guess a and b or one and two with
you number one donald trump said
why do people like dr fauci but they
don't like trump
why does dr fauci have a high approval
and trump has a low approval when fauci
works for trump trump couldn't
understand it it was really really weird
also yesterday and we already went over
this in the last segment donald trump
told a black reporter i believe maybe
the one black reporter in the room
that he looks like nearly 80 year old
jewish man michael bloomberg so that was
weird in its own way but none of that
is as crazy as what we're now going to
talk about trump almost seems normal
in those instances compared to what i'm
going to talk about now
donald trump jr was temporarily limited
on twitter yesterday
because he shared a video of a doctor
named stella emmanuel
who spoke in favor of hydroxychloroquine
for coronavirus and believes having sex
with demons can cause illness
and believes there's a plan to vaccinate
americans from becoming
religious that'd be an interesting
vaccine and donald trump shared the
exact same video of stella emmanuel to
his 84 million twitter followers but
later took it down once the uh you know
what started to hit the fan
now to avoid problems ourselves i'm not
going to play the video for you
but you can find the video easily if you
want to
the same doctor stella emmanuel said
you don't need to wear a mask which is
actually
dangerous disinformation she also said
that there's already a cure out there
for coronavirus
so trump was asked about her during the
press briefing this is a really good
video you're going to hear cnn reporter
caitlin collins list
some of the things that stella emanuel
said and believes
and trump doubles down check this out
and then when caitlyn collins tries to
follow up
trump triggered ends the press briefing
immediately
and walks out of the room the woman that
you said is a great doctor
in that video that you retweeted last
night said that masks don't work and
there is a cure for covid19
both of which health experts say is not
true she's also made videos saying
that doctors make medicine using dna
from
aliens and that they're trying to create
a vaccine to make you immune from
becoming religious maybe it's the same
maybe it's not but i i can't i can tell
you this
she was on air along with many other
doctors
they were big fans of hydroxy
chloroquine
and i thought she was very impressive in
the sense that from where she came i
don't know which country she comes from
but she said that she's had tremendous
success with hundreds of different
patients
and i thought her voice was an important
voice but i know nothing about her
last week real quick thank you very much
your retweets everybody you in trouble
don't you now
i'm going to admit something to you
yesterday
throughout the day i sort of heard
rumblings about
don jr was limited on twitter for
sharing some video but i was busy
preparing the show the podcast
etc and then i heard something about
demon sperm trending on twitter but i
was busy
preparing for my live stream and so i
didn't really
follow the story closely you know you
hear about demon sperm i didn't know it
was related to don jr didn't pay much
attention i thought well demon sperm
must be some light
hearted story maybe it's something from
a video game who knows
and then meanwhile don jr was limited on
twitter i thought maybe there's a
comedic element here there's a meme
element a joke i don't know
i didn't consider for a second that the
entire
thing could have been related to
something that donald trump
was promoting himself she believes in
demonic
sperm that can cause gynecological
problems
and that's who donald trump is saying
has a voice that should really be heard
on the issue of coronavirus and on the
issue of hydroxychloroquine
this is also intense by the way
yesterday stella emanuel tweeted out an
article written
about her in the daily beast look at
what she wrote she tweeted quote
the daily beast did a great job
summarizing
our deliverance ministry
and ex i hope you're sitting down and
exposing incubus
and succubus thank you daily beast
if you need deliverance from these
spirits
contact us deliverance ministry
one she seems to be promoting almost
like an exorcism of some kind
show us the alien dna she show us the
vaccine
that pr by the way a vaccine to prevent
people from becoming religious
would be very interesting in a number of
ways
the country may be better off if such a
vaccine actually existed on the net now
i know that i'm not saying all religion
is bad or anything like that but on the
net we might be better off with such a
vaccine
imagine a pres imagine anyone
calling this woman a highly respected
doctor whose voice is important
then realize that it's the president of
the united states who is doing it so
what i want to think about is is trump
this stupid or does donald trump just
prioritize
angering the left and remember prior to
trumpism
the three main wings of the american
right
were small government type liberty
folks you know people like in the tea
party and the
more libertarian-minded the low-tax
pro-business
conservatives like mitt romney as an
example who aren't
the most socially conservative people
but sometimes they are but it's really
not as much about socialist
issues as it is about low taxes and a
pro-business environment and then the
third wing would be
the religious conservatives whose
priority is you know often evangelical
christians who care the most about
abortion
social issues gay marriage etc under
trumpism there's this fourth wing
and it's a wing that as i discussed
yesterday with coleman hughes
it's not really about policy it's about
angering the other side
and so is that what trump is
fundamentally doing here and cow towing
to and placating just
if the left thinks this woman's crazy
then i should defend her
and is it as simple as that uh or
does trump genuinely think that this is
somebody that should be listened to i
mean i just don't get it i don't i don't
really know what's but
what this is all about and it's always
easy to say it's meant to be a
distraction it's meant to be a
distraction from
the coronavirus death toll which spiked
over 1200 yesterday for the first time
in a while
or it's meant to be a distraction from
the fact that trump's losing every poll
or
you know you can always say it's a
distraction but i think that there's
probably some deeper
explanation or understanding that we
could have here insane
absolutely insane and i i don't have the
clip but i guess today when trump was
doing the helicopter press conference
just
as he was walking out to his chopper he
was asked again
about this dr stella emanuel and like
tripled down on it although i haven't
seen that video yet
i will take a look at it let me know
what you think explains what's going on
here
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video